Good morning, John, we are about to have gone
around the sun again.
That's right, my next Vlogbrothers video will
be made in the year 2015.
Over on SciShow, Michael Aranda just gave
us some of the science superlatives of 2014:
the deepest diving whale ever recorded, the
most Earth-like planet, the highest CO2 emissions,
and the warmest months ever recorded.
2014 has been a big year in science, but it's
also been a big year in general, so here on
Vlogbrothers where things are more general,
let's talk about some of the biggest, bestest,
superlative-est things that happened this
year.
First, with the very likely possibility that
this will have been the warmest year ever
recorded, and while we are an adaptable species,
and I do have a lot of faith in us, figuring
out how to grow all the food we need to grow
with water landing in different places than
it used to land, and protecting all of the
infrastructure we already have with new infrastructure
that's going to be very expensive... (groan).
But there's also good news.
2014 saw the youngest ever recipient of the
Nobel Peace Prize.
Malala Yousafzai's acceptance speech made
me cry, it probably will make you cry too
if you watch it, and it also gave me hope
about some very depressing, seemingly hopeless
situations, so that's -- and she's 17.
What was I doing when I was 17?
I can't even talk about it.
I -- no.
It was also probably the best year ever to
be a nerd.
Sherlock came back, Orphan Black is awesome,
we're getting new Star Wars movies and new
Star Trek movies, and new Avengers movies,
we had a new X-Men movie, new Doctor, new
Veronica Mars, new Cosmos.
We landed a probe on a comet, Curiosity realized
that it's definitely for sure roving around
on an ancient Martian lakebed, got a female
Thor, and a black Captain America.
It's been a good year.
I'll also venture to say that it's the first
year in decades when America broadly decided
that it had to confront its, you know, sort
of mass, like, racism.
That's what it -- that's -- yeah.
Michael Brown, Eric Garner, John Crawford,
12-year-old Tamir Rice, were all killed by
police officers and were all unarmed.
In and of itself, that's actually not unusual,
which is a sad thing to have to say.
Unarmed black men are shot and killed by police
officers every year.
This isn't like a new explosion of police
shootings.
What's different is all of the Americans,
mostly Americans of color, who stood up and
said that they have had enough, and advanced
a national dialogue about police wearing body
cameras, about the difficulties of being a
person of color in America, about the systemic
racism in the justice system.
These are problems that we've always had,
but that we haven't talked about for a long
time, like somehow racism went away after
segregation.
Discussions about systemic sexism were also
advanced, with Emma Watson's he-for-she speech
at the United Nations, and that video that
got like 30 million views of this woman just
walking around New York being harassed.
One final first for you: here in Missoula,
Montana we had our first same-sex marriage
at the courthouse, which just, I can't believe
it took so long, but it happened.
As with any year, there's been good and there's
been bad, and we talk more about the bad than
about the good, but maybe that will lead us
to fighting against the bad so that next year,
in 2015, there will be less of it, though
I'm sure the amount of it that we have is
what we will mostly talk about.
Again.
As always.
With help from some people on Twitter, I've
created a playlist of some of the most important
YouTube videos of 2014, including Emma Watson
and Malala's speeches, and CGP Grey talking
about why maybe in the future, jobs won't
exist.
Should you be happy or sad?
I'm not sure.
Everyone, thank you for another great year
here at Vlogbrothers, and John, I'll see you
on Tuesday.